why are we friends on the dick Sherlock
Holmes are you just sitting there
inserting and I'm inserting your heart
stop dry humping the doorknob was like
by generations why are you wearing a
shirt as a little a guy
save them are together sexual power whoa
doesn't work four five six seven eight I
picked so seven I fish you choose option
option number six and number one the
exit game I just get get the [ __ ] out of
here Charlie Matheson jr. know it looks
like a white version of my friend will
huh I hear crows stirring okay he has
the controller and I have the headphones
so he can't hear anything and I can but
I can't I don't have any control I think
that's where you go um I don't know oh
hey look here's the thing i got that
creepy magazine he came for me oh you
gross what how many times does it say
six three times what ah boys after an
area a tighter hiker after an arid and
air arid height area hiker failed to
report back to park staff Rangers feared
and under hug that your handwriting is
bad okay who is that hang on all right
take these headphones you have to
continue this epic journey on your own
yeah hang on ah don't you worry guys at
least I my house there's a fog line for
everything my god what did you hear
something you know I just hear my
footsteps oh my god whoa oh Danya well
this is pretty great what's happening
out you see you know but I see this
house how many houses are there there's
like 80 brokencyde harp oh my god she's
so scary
I'm so paranoid right now just wish I
could hide Lock this door behind me and
just hide in this this whatever it's
called yes tough on a chair I brought
this chair my dog Wow be careful I
almost hit my toe no I didn't hear like
a foot away oh hey what Oh microwave
maybe I can make some nachos oh wait you
see that those cups there you should try
and make some hot cocoa whoa whoa what
did you do what the hell is that I swear
if your brother went to go get a third
soda I'm gonna slap him oh no I deseos
windows do you see him anywhere
huh you found any paper will try and
look hired they like usually stuck to
walls oh here's here's one of eight
pages collected have to find me what huh
oh there's noises man I was so scary did
you see him I was looking away in
returning a text message I just green it
just turned green ah ha ha ha ha there's
a green light of here hold on let's
switch off okay swap you can hear an
ayala play ok ok ok as we find them he
gets more and more aggressive what what
he's behind me is that him what oh that
look like him my god why do you find
another one hey we have to find them
it's the goal you turn on lights no
those lights were just already on
do they at least protect you okay the
car I don't think lights protect you at
all is there is there a note on this car
I don't know oh there is Oh God right
round of the ride oh it's weird oh oh my
god oh my god oh my god so light all
right said I so paw I sell propane and
propane accessories I saw why and I was
like a week I keep thinking every single
light is his face what oh it's over
there is that is that a no what is it
got it Oh hear that there were half ways
wah wah got it halfway done count yella
your stupid business suit he's like
Nosferatu yeah he like I have a face had
no face but that head 0 face instead of
some face like just take the face slider
and then just slide it back and then
there's no face
ha ha ha what no stop love you betta
Michael oh just like Jackson Jackson's
like a foot taller than me i'm so salt
about it it's okay cuz he has bad
posture great right please stop oh dude
you can't even check this place good
because hey no hard react your quarter
no there's always a way just walking
back and forth between the same strip of
land forever what's over there nothing i
was there already stop it oh my god run
hope my battery doesn't run out oh god
my god I'm just kidding haha let's run
at him and kick his ass I don't want to
actually do that it's not gonna protect
it yeah whoa i just walked over and fine
whoo oh my god oh oh no I don't like it
I don't like it I like it I like it I
like I don't like it I need to make up
for that one guy not being here I don't
like it hello oh hey finally somewhere
where we consider panting hey oh yes
finally I can rush late
ah where's pages page page are you
finding it yet stopping yeah like never
before can't stop looking good yeah I'm
never before hahaha oh not another one
is it all ok we need more bathroom
breaks good good Oh No ok this is worse
than alien isolation actually this is
not as bad as alien isolation mean
Jackson should do more parts for alien
isolation where we actually get to spook
oh he's walking towards me yeah he was
walking on do you see that oh my god
that noise that got me so bye oh boy gun
he's actually we can see him moving that
noise I was already here oh there was
this a whole guy
you